I'm here to present the nominees for
Actor in a supporting role it's a very
eclectic group young and mature American
and foreign they do however have one
thing in common they're all very
supportive the nominees for actor in a
supporting role are Leonardo DiCaprio in
What's Eating Gilbert Grape
ray Fiennes in Schindler's List Tommy
Lee Jones in the fugitive John Malkovich
in the line of fire Pete Postlethwaite
in the name of the Father
and the Oscar goes to the Oscar goes to
Tommy Lee Jones
my thanks to the Academy for the very
finest the greatest award that any actor
can ever receive the only thing a man
can say at a time like this is I am not
really bald actually I'm I'm lucky
enough to be working and and for that I
have to thank the boss Bob Daley the
other boss Terry Semel I'm also our
9-mil Sean Steve Luther Arnold cope
Wilson Andy Davis Peter McGregor Scott
michael Chapman my friends bill Jacobson
and Michael black my dear and courageous
family
Victoria Kimberly and Austin Jones above
all I think a man who needs no support
at all Harrison Ford for all of you
thanks for the work
you